Vamos a repasar un poco el valor absoluto
antes de meternos en las ecuaciones con el
valor absoluto, porque cuando yo hablaba del
valor absoluto, realmente en lo que estaba
pensando era en una distancia, por ejemplo, si me tomo el valor absoluto de -1, me estoy fijando,
que tan lejos está el -1 del 0.
Si nosotros tomamos aquí una recta numérica...
y déjame dibujar una mejor recta numérica,
me gusta más ésta...
y aquí está el 0, el -1 si te das cuenta
está a 1 unidad de distancia del 0,
por lo tanto, el valor absoluto de -1 es 1 y de igual manera, si yo me tomo el valor absoluto de 1,
te das cuenta que la distancia del 1 al 0 es 1, por lo tanto, también el valor absoluto de 1 es 1.
Y bueno, esta es una forma de pensarlo, como la distancia que tiene un número al 0,
pero también hay otra forma de pensarlo.
Por ejemplo, si me tomo el valor absoluto
de -7346, esto siempre me lo manda positivo,
los números negativos me lo mandan a su versión
en positivo, mientras que los números positivos
se quedan en su versión en positivo.
Y bueno, esto nos da pie a pensar en ecuaciones
con valor absoluto, si nosotros tenemos por
ejemplo "x" menos 5,
el valor absoluto de "x" menos 5 igual a 10 y quiero resolver a esta ecuación,
¿cómo la resuelvo?
Bueno, pues una forma de pensarlo es,
¿qué números están a una distancia de
10 unidades del 5?
O tal vez otra forma de pensarlo es
¿qué números si le tomas el valor absoluto nos da 10?
y a esos números hay que igualarlos a "x" menos 5, esto es una forma sistemática de verlo
y de hecho es la mejor forma de resolver
este tipo de ecuaciones.
Así que voy a poner primero, "x" menos 5 es igual a 10 porque date cuenta que el valor absoluto de 10 es 10,
si "x" menos 5 vale 10, entonces me voy a tomar el valor absoluto de 10, pero el valor absoluto de 10 es 10,
entonces se cumpliría esta ecuación.
Pero también existe otro,
también puedes tomar como "x" menos 5 igual a -10, si esta parte de aquí adentro es -10
y le tomas el valor absoluto a -10, pues el valor absoluto
de -10 también es 10,
recuerda que lo manda a su versión en positivo. Por lo tanto, ya tenemos aquí dos ecuaciones
y por lo tanto, dos posibles resultados o "x" menos 5 es igual a 10,  de aquí yo puedo sumar 5
de ambos lados de la ecuación, me queda que "x" es igual a 15 o en su dado caso
"x" menos 5 es igual a -10 y si sumo 5 de ambos lados de la ecuación, me queda que "x" es igual a -5.
Ambos valores de "x" que acabo de encontrar,
"x" igual a 15 y "x" igual a -5, son ambos
la respuesta de esta ecuación con valor absoluto,
15 menos 5 es 10 y el valor absoluto de 10 es 10 y -5 menos 5 es -10 y el valor absoluto de -10 es 10,
por lo tanto ambos cumplen y ambos son mi soluciones de esta ecuación con valor absoluto
y se me antoja hacer otro ejemplo,
así que vamos a bajarnos para acá.
Así que vamos a tomarnos otra ecuación.
Y se me ocurre poner "x" más 2 esto igual a 6,
ésta tampoco está tan difícil, sin embargo lo que quiero que veas es el mismo concepto
o "x" más 2 es igual a 6 positivo,
porque si el valor absoluto de 6 es 6,
entonces "x" más dos podría ser 6 ó en su dado caso tenemos una segunda solución,
si "x" más 2 es igual a -6, porque recuerda que el valor
absoluto de -6 también es 6, por lo tanto
"x" más 2 ó puede ser 6 ó puede ser -6.
Y en el primer caso si resto 2 de ambos lados
de la ecuación, me queda que "x" es igual
a 4, mientras que en el segundo caso,
"x" es igual a -8, si paso el 2 del otro lado
con signo contrario,
o "x" es igual a 4 ó "x" es igual a -8 y así de fácil y así de sencillo podemos resolver esta ecuación
con valor absoluto.Y vamos a ver que si es cierto,  porque también lo podrías ver como una distancia,
podrías pensar que esto es lo mismo que "x" menos -2 igual a 6 y pensar
¿cuáles son los números que están a una
distancia de 6 del -2?
Fíjate bien, aquí arriba teníamos por ejemplo,
cuales son los números que están a una distancia
de 10 del 5, aquí es lo mismo,
¿cuáles son los números que están a una distancia de 6 del -2? Y bueno, pues la respuesta es 4 y -8.
4 está a una distancia de 6 del -2 y -8 también, puedes hacer una recta numérica para comprobarlo
por ti mismo, pero bueno, ya que me están gustando mucho los ejemplos, vamos a hacer otro ejemplo.
Me voy a tomar un ejemplo un poco más difícil, pero te vas a ver que tampoco es nada del otro mundo.
Me voy a tomar el valor absoluto de "4x" menos 1, esto igual a 19, y si te das cuenta realmente tampoco
hay tanta ciencia en esto, lo único que hice es poner una ecuación un poco más difícil de resolver,
pero bueno, aquí está diciendo que "4x" menos 1,
puede ser en su dado caso 19
ó también "4x" menos 1, recuerda que tenemos una segunda solución,
"4x" menos 1 puede ser también igual a -19,
"4x" menos 1 es igual a -19 y bueno,
si de la primera ecuación despejamos a "x", primero vamos a pasar el 1 de ambos lados de la ecuación
y lo vamos a pasar sumando, entonces
me queda que "4x" es igual a 20,
también voy a hacer lo mismo de este lado de la ecuación, me va a quedar que "4x" es igual a  -19 más 1
que es -18 y después voy a dividir ambos
lados de la ecuación entre 4,
me queda que "x" es igual a 5 en este caso, mientras que en el otro si divido ambos lados entre 4
me queda que "x" es igual a -18/4,
o en  su dado caso -9/2...
-9/2, ¡y ya está!, aquí tengo la solución de esta ecuación que tiene valor absoluto o "x" igual a 5 o "x" igual a -9/2,
resuelven esta ecuación con valor absoluto, ambas son
soluciones de esta ecuación con valor absoluto,
4 por 5 = 20 menos 1 me da 19 y después 4
por -9/2 me da -18, -1 es -19
y cuando tomo el valor absoluto también me da 19, por lo tanto, ya aquí tengo mis dos soluciones
y ahora vamos a ver otra cosa un poco distinta.
Vamos a pensar ahora en una función que tenga que ver con valor absoluto.
Me voy a tomar la función "y" es igual al
valor absoluto de "x" más 3.
¿Cómo se ve la gráfica de esta función?
Sin embargo lo primero que quiero que pienses
de esta función, es en dos casos,
el primer caso puede ser que "x" más 3 sea positivo y cuando tomamos el valor absoluto de algo positivo
se queda igual, entonces me queda
"x" más 3 es mayor que 0,
es algo positivo y también tenemos otro caso que "x" más 3 sea menor que 0,
es decir, tomar el valor absoluto de un número negativo.
Si "x" más 3 es mayor que 0,
entonces la función queda tal cual porque recuerda que el valor absoluto de algo positivo es el mismo,
por lo tanto me quedaría "y" es igual a "x"más
3 y date cuenta que se queda igual porque
cuando yo tengo un número positivo y le tomo
el valor absoluto, se queda el mismo número.
Y bueno, si de aquí despejo a "x" en esta
desigualdad, voy a obtener que "x" es mayor que -3,
si resto de ambos lados de la ecuación
o más bien, de ambos lados de la desigualdad,
3, me queda que "x" es mayor que -3.
Bueno, este es mi primer caso,
cuando "x" más 3 es mayor que 0, ahora también tengo
otro caso, que "x" más 3 sea menor que 0,
si "x" más 3 es menor que 0, date cuenta
que esto que está aquí adentro va a ser negativo,
y entonces, cuando me tomo el valor absoluto de algo negativo, lo convierto en positivo
y eso en matemáticas quiere decir
que lo voy a multiplicar por menos,
es decir que "y" me va a quedar igual a -"x" más 3,
¿y cómo sé eso?
pues porque fíjate en esto, si yo me tomo
el valor absoluto de algo negativo,
pues la función valor absoluto lo que haces es mandármela a positivo, con el mismo valor,
entonces ¿cómo convierto algo negativo a positivo?
Pues multiplicándolo por menos.
Por ejemplo, el valor absoluto de -5 es 5,
lo único que hice fue multiplicar el -5 por menos
para que me diera 5 positivo.
Es justo por eso que me queda que "y" es igual a
-"x" más 3, en paréntesis.
Y bueno, si de aquí despejo a "x",
me queda que esta función es cierta
cuando "x" es menor que -3,
es decir que estoy separando esta función en dos partes, cuando "x" más 3 es menor que 0,
cuando lo que está dentro del valor
absoluto es menor que 0
y cuando lo que está dentro del valor
absoluto es mayor que 0.
Así que vamos a ver cómo se ve la gráfica de esto.
Déjame dibujar dos ejes, este es mi eje de las "x" y este es mi eje de las "y" y bueno,
lo primero que voy a hacer es fijarme en
la primera ecuación,
en la ecuación de morado y tengo "y" es
igual a -"x" más 3,
esto es exactamente lo mismo y voy a distribuir en menos, que "-x" menos 3.
Y por lo tanto date cuenta que la gráfica
de esto es una línea recta,
la cual tiene como ordenada al origen a -3, es decir, corta en el eje de las "y" a -3...
vamos a ponerlo aquí...
-1, -2, -3... pasa por este punto y después
si despejamos a "x", vamos a ver que corta
el eje de las "x" también en -3 porque cuando
"y" es igual a 0, me queda que 0 es igual a "-x" menos 3 y si de aquí despejo a "x" me queda que "x" vale -3
Por lo tanto, también intersecta al eje de
las "x", en el valor de -3.
Y como es una recta, pues entonces ya tengo dos puntos y ya puedo dibujar esta recta, es algo así...
déjame tomar estos valores y déjame tratar
de trazar estar recta lo mejor posible,
tanto para aquí como para acá.
Bueno, esto es si "x" más 3 es menor que 0,
pero ahora vamos a fijarnos qué es lo que
pasa con mi segunda información,
yo sé que la gráfica se ve como "y" es igual a "x" más 3, por cierto, intersecta al eje de las
"y" en el valor de 3 positivo, si quiero encontrar
otro punto, cuando "y" vale 0 "x" vale -3,
es decir que también pasa por este punto
y ya puedo dibujar de aquí mi recta.
Mi segunda recta de mi segunda información
que me dan se ve como esta recta de amarillo,
ya tengo mis dos rectas de las
informaciones que me dan.
Ahora vamos a fijarnos en algo con mucho cuidado,
dice, se cumple la ecuación de morado
cuando "x" es menor que -3.
Es decir, todos los valores de "x"
que sean menores que -3 pues son todos estos que están aquí, es justo lo que estoy poniendo,
mientras que por otra parte, en mi segunda información
me dice que "x" es mayor que -3,
es decir que funciona esta recta cuando "x" es mayor
que -3 y por lo tanto, esto otro de rojo que
estoy poniendo aquí... ¡y ya está!
Ya con esto tenemos la gráfica de esta función
en valor absoluto, es esto de rojo que me
quedó, esta V.
Cuando "x" es menor que -3, se comporta como
la gráfica que tenemos de morado,
mientras cuando "x" es mayor que -3 se comporta como
la gráfica de amarillo
y nos queda esta V de color rojo.
Esta es nuestra V gráfica que representa a la función con valor absoluto con la que empezamos.